set goals by the new goal goal set up
pretty high gold schools don't give up
on your goals set goals go set and gold
you absolutely must have those goals
hello believe nation today we're going
to look at how you can set goals and not
give up I remember as you watch the
video if somebody says something that
really means something to you is really
impactful write it down in the comments
below and put quotes around it so other
people can benefit and be inspired as
well make a list of 101 things you want
to achieve before you die now I was
sharing this with someone last night
they said God that just seems like a
really big task I'm a single mom I don't
have any time when am I gonna do that we
know that one of the things about high
achievers they all have goals only 10%
of Americans set goals every year 10% I
can go to sales conferences people that
are the learning stuff hear it over and
over
how many 10% we also know the same 3 to
10 percent control 90% of the resources
of the world so literally without goals
your directionless you will be you see
people without goals get used by other
people who have them people that don't
have goals work for people who do and so
you want to be someone who picks up and
gets clear about what you want
make a list 101 goals I want to go to
Paris I want to you know skydive I want
to bungee cord jump I want to play the
guitar I want to learn to juggle I want
to learn two magic tricks for the kids I
want to go to the Olympics in Beijing
whatever it is make the list and you'll
see there's a lot of stuff under there
that you've kind of put down that you
want and you can have anything you want
you know when you don't see limits
because like if you're coming from a
space where you're actually ambitious
out the ambition is to learn behavior I
think it's a part of a person's natural
character so I always no matter what I
accomplish you're gonna see me back at
your show saying I think I got another
idea I can make this work
Hey are you gonna be like this guy just
will stop I'll tell you in advance yeah
you see me hahahaha but like you know I
get means if idiot puts himself on not
think that means before you but you know
like I always find a new goal set for
myself and work towards accomplishing it
because I you know that's what's really
excites me that's what makes me happy
like when it when it works a lot of
times there's nothing around to support
it it's just me dreams without goals are
just dreaming and the ultimately fuel
disappointment goals on the road to
achievement cannot be achieved without
discipline and consistency I pray that
you all put your shoes way under the bed
at night so that you got to get on your
knees in the morning I'm wondering if
you have any personal tricks on how you
keep yourself motivated I set a pretty
high goals for myself
they're usually higher than what I think
most other people said from upset for me
and I just em up I'm very driven to
achieve them I'm a goal-oriented
individual and and I just am very driven
to achieve those goals a lot of times my
shoes people are not setting goals that
will be something that somebody who
becomes rich or is could do anything you
got to be excited about working on that
for ten years so you got to have a big
enough coal that you know you attract
the best people and you retain them and
you keep them focused and then my
experience you don't go wrong you know
maybe you don't hit it next year or
maybe you fail entirely and you discover
something more exciting to work on with
the same set of people I would say to
continue to work hard and don't give up
on your goals and I know for me like I
said I grew up watching my family
struggle and I grew up with a family
that was successful but not
successful and I believe with hard work
and with a goal and and love and
positivity then eventually we're going
to be fine these cycles because you want
to achieve certain things in your life
you know whether it's golf for me or you
know whether it's buying a house for for
someone else or whether it's securing a
good job or have a family or whatever it
is there's many different reasons why
you set goals and I obviously have a lot
of goals for my career and I have a lot
of goals for my life as well but I think
it's important to set goals because it
means you don't get complacent you know
you always have something to aim for
you can set result-oriented goals where
you know it's a long-term goal or you
can you can set little short-term goals
to help you get to that long-term goal
so instead of saying I want to win the
Masters I'll say what will help me win
the Masters and what I need to improve
to get there after I left University I
was working on Wall Street I was an oil
trader on Wall Street for two years
hated it it was the worst experience of
my entire life I was the victim of bad
culture and knew I wanted to be creative
a great one and when I was growing up I
realized I had one goal in life right
and that was to get as wealthy as
possible as quickly as possible and I
realized that there are three ways that
you're honest about very real about that
there are three ways to do it the first
was to be an actor an athlete that
didn't work out for me at all the second
way was to work on Wall Street hated it
and I said damn I've already exhausted
two of the three the last one was
entrepreneurship and the day I came to
that realization I said you know I hate
Wall Street I want to get as far away
from this place literally and
figuratively as possible there's a
school called Stanford I think it's well
known for entrepreneurship I didn't
really know what that meant let me apply
and fortunately I got in and it wasn't
until literally I got out in August of
2000 or 2008 that I saw other 24 year
olds not only making millions of dollars
but fundamentally changing the world and
I knew I wanted to be a part of that and
kind of the rest is history at that
point
I've been terrible about setting goals
all my life and trying to get there and
one of my one of my goals as you well
know was to make that the best store in
Arkansas that's right and we got there
before we left town we came became the
bigger story
most profitable well uh Ben Franklin
store in the state of Arkansas I want to
talk a little bit about goes on the
light of how do you lose 37 pounds and
write a book I'm just going to kind of
give you that as an example for 24 years
of my adult life by choice I weighed
well over 200 pounds I say by choice
because you see I have never
accidentally eaten anything I mean it's
always been deliberate and when I choose
to eat too much today I have chosen to
weigh too much
tomorrow you can choose to set goals and
realize your potential or you can choose
not to set them now if you choose not to
set them you got to understand that the
consequences are not going to be good
down the road for 24 years I was going
to lose that way as a matter of fact in
24 years I lost several thousand pounds
of weight I mean if you already know
exactly what I'm talking about but it
wasn't until I wrote it down put a date
on it list of the obstacles I had to
overcome identify the people the groups
organizations I needed to work with
spelled out a plan of action set that
time limit in there and identified all
of the benefits to me it was only when I
did that that the goal became a reality
and I lost the weight for 10 or 15 years
I was going to write a book you know
anybody who's it going to do just a
whole lot of things folks I was going to
write a book but it wasn't until I got
busy writing the book and writing the
plans first before the book ever
materialized now if it sounds like I'm
trying to sell you on heaven goals how
many of you are getting close already
how many of you being coming convinced
right quick like that you need to have
those gold there's no question about it
the immortal JCPenney many many years
ago said give me a stock clerk with a
goal and I'll give you a man will make
history but give me a man without a goal
and I'll give you a stock clerk now the
interesting thing is goes do not care
who has them let me give you a classic
example of the way they work in 1950 a
war-torn devastated to Japan a nation
who had lost an incredibly high
percentage of its young men their cities
were in ruins had been bombed out but in
1950 they got together they meaning
industry and government got together and
set a goal the goal was we're going to
be the number one nation in the world
during the 1950's in the production of
textiles in 1959 ladies and gentlemen
they accomplished that objective in 1960
they said another go we're going to be
the number one nation in the world in
the production of steel now when you
understand there's no iron ore in Japan
of any significance there's no coal of
any significance there we're going to be
the number one nation in the world in
the production of steel it seemed like
an absurd goal and yet they reached
their objectives they've taken all of
the steps in 1970 the Japanese said
another goal they said during the
seventies will be the number one nation
in the world in the production of
automobiles they missed it folks one
year it took them until 1980 in 1980
they said another gold and this time
their goal was we're going to be the
number one nation in the world in the
production of computers and electronics
yes indeed ladies and gentlemen you
absolutely must have those goals
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
you thought of the video what changes
are going to make in your life for
business as a result of watching this
leave it in the comments below and I
will join in the discussion I also want
to give a quick shout out to Andy Walker
from monopoly calm and you thank you so
much for picking up a cup in my book
really really really means a lot to me
those are you watching if you want a
chance at a shout out in a future video
as well as a bunch of free awesome
bonuses make sure to pick up a copy of
the book and email in your receipt so we
can keep track thank you guys so much
for watching
continue
to believe or whatever your one word is
and I'll see you soon